[Music]
what is it with characters and movies
with active chessboards and no one to
play with
is it to subtly remind the audience that
this guy is smart as if the two hours of
movie wouldn't be able to cover that on
its own you actually fought to get
reassigned here yeah what's up with that
by the way
Mills mentions in passing he wants to do
some good but that is the only reason he
moves him and poor Gwyneth to this
godforsaken City gonna remove a sin for
the opening credit yep the opening
credits which were revolutionary and set
the proper mood for the movie are about
to see often when you are insane you
feel the need to black out words on a
pregnancy and your sense of smell
article if the public were to get their
hands on this information many of our
top spies overseas would be discovered I
mean really the only thing the opening
credits shows us is that John Doe is an
excellent scrapbooker as we will soon
find out about a third of this movie
will be people putting on ties the other
third will be scenes in the ring and yet
despite this the movie remains a
masterpiece discuss this unknown city
loss new angel' york will have constant
rain for seven days and absolutely no
flooding I know this cops not a
detective but is that seriously this
assholes criteria for confirming this
dude to death sure the victims in
terrible shape and the fact that he's
toast is pretty obvious but even a
rent-a-cop would check vital signs also
we've seen that the electricity works
since the TVs and lights are on in
living room so could they not put on an
overhead in the kitchen or is it against
this movie's rules to have any lighting
said this was learned
Oh what then why they was homicide
immediately called him to investigate
Oh wonderful very moody David Fincher's
reactions to the dailies somehow made it
into the script as you can tell this
movie was supposed to be the story of
Noah at one point the original script
followed the Bible closely but they
added a seven deadly sins plot and
changed all the characters the rain no
stay shut in who never went outside and
yet anger John Doe so much at the sight
of him that he needed to kill it
I'm wondering did John Doe answer
help-wanted ads for people who were
wreck losses until he found his gluttony
this was 1995 so II gluttony wasn't
around them the bucket beneath him kept
on serving took his time to car and I
said this could have gone on for more
than 12 hours what a hilariously
specific time frame this coroner came up
with I mean does he have previous
experience on a case where someone was
forced to eat himself to death and made
a second trip to the supermarket so a
man just after spending the last several
minutes bitching about being taken
seriously as a detective detective Mills
here refuses to provide any details on
his first case in the precinct sergeant
Hartman which is it can you swap cases
or can't you I'm beginning to think John
Doe didn't hate people because of their
deadly sins but because they had to TBS
the lawyer here and the gluttony guy
earlier we're going to go live downtown
the forensics guys turn on the TVs to
have some background noise while they
were working on the crime scene because
otherwise this is extremely convenient
not only are they on
but that Mills comes in right as the
press conference for the very case he's
working on begins I know they're
probably still unpacking their clothes
from the move but chased Mill
specifically order this shirt with extra
wrinkles but every newspaper in town had
this story as their headline even if
Gould were discovered early in the
morning there's no way all the
newspapers would be able to stop the
presses and get this entire story
printed this keep out sticker was placed
on the inside of the door of a crime
scene I guess that's a prank
John Doe was betting so much on
Somerset's great detective skills that
he fed his victim wood shards from the
floor in front of the refrigerator
look I'm not knocking Somerset this was
a terrific deduction but the fact that
doe knew he'd be able to figure it out
is yet more bull than this bullshit II
plant sloth wrath pride lust and envy
several credits that's great pal but I
need a destination otherwise we're going
to the default far away from here which
is Manhattan Kansas the economy was
great back in 1995 because libraries
could afford to have multiple night
watchmen guarding books overnight that
nobody wants to read anyway
sick burn man but do these assholes
really sit around and listen to Bach
when they play poker reading really
getting the feeling that Somerset's just
skipping right to the pictures in these
great works of literature probably on
the off chance he might see some hand
drawn boobs
Somerset writes a note to mills telling
him he might want to check out some
books on the seven deadly sins probably
to understand the killer better but how
does that get them closer to the killer
it literally could be anyone feel like
this is something a smart person tells
themselves they need to do but they end
up wasting time reading The Canterbury
Tales when they should be interviewing
all the Catholics in the area apparently
after a 16-hour copying scene Somerset
was able to fit all those copies into an
envelope without massively inflating it
seriously my guess is that David Fincher
held stock and a rain machine company
when he decided to do this project
William I'm less concerned about this
semi an appropriate question than I am
the previous conversation was boring
enough that Somerset started folding a
fucking napkin to keep his attention
real estate so this is the place two
times still wondering why will he only
brings you for five minutes at a time
yeah you guys were shopping for
apartments and you agreed to look at one
several times five minutes at a time and
by the way how did this real estate guy
time the fucking crane so well during
that many visits damn I love this cast
now listen the body was found on Tuesday
morning the office was closed on Monday
which means I could have gotten in on
Friday they load to the cleaning crew
left and had his way with gould all day
saturday they'll go on to explain that
his wife was out of town during all of
this but she didn't try to contact her
husband for four days was what attrition
is when you regret your sins but not
because you love God religious issue
safe house that's supposed to be a house
of safety leaves the front door wide the
fuck open luckily all these shots of a
dead Gould are the perfect sign is to be
redacted with a regular post-it note
[Music]
funny I watched that scene and I don't
remember Mills ever telling mrs. Gould
that he wanted to catch this guy may
have happened off screen but that
doesn't count dying once on a deserted
island save them in case we get rescued
thankfully Mills interjects here because
Somerset was running low on metaphors
for the emptiness of life of a detective
in this town he's got a long history of
serious mental health
his parents gave him a very strict
Southern Baptist upbringing since I
added this stupidly specific last detail
to this briefing I'd also like to
mention that his favorite food is
lasagna
he loves Mad About You and he prefers
blue underwear the guy they're about to
arrest is victim number three the sloth
victim sloth defined by the Catholic
faith is first and foremost very hard to
define it's basically a person who can't
move who doesn't care about himself or
others
John Doe apparently defines it as almost
every criminals rap sheet is larger by
the way as recently safety like oh my
gosh is the captain continuing this
briefing while walking the entire team
down a staircase this ensures that only
part of the team will actually hear the
information apparently the police do not
believe any other crime is scheduled
today then send the entire force to pick
up a guy who's easily been arrested
several times in the past never took
never took a bullet pulled my gun once
shot it once I'm shadowing SWAT before
dicks then why the hell weren't you at
the front of the line then gotta ask if
this guy smells this bad what air
fresheners really conceal it wouldn't
the neighbors smell him anyway even so
is the mix of every different air
freshener scent really that more
appealing than the funk of this dudes
rotting body I think it's hilarious that
John Doe hung tons of air fresheners on
the ceiling but decided to hang one on
the lamp just for good measure okay guys
this is one of the most intense moments
in film history here it's set up so well
I mean there's no way this guy's alive
right and he's not the killer so there's
nothing in your brain that tells you
this scare is coming it deserves five
cents off and therefore we will grant it
he's experienced about as much pain and
suffering as anyone I've encountered
give or take and he's still that's held
to look forward to Jesus Christ it
sounds like this doctor is on his last
week of work don't let this guy near any
family members after our car crash sorry
folks your son died from horrible brain
injuries sustained in the crash I just
wanted you to hear from me that God is
dead and no one cares to quote a
favorite musician of mine also give or
take what this doctor seen a case that's
anywhere near this level of suffering
you know the kind of suffering that
makes you eat your own pink tongue I
hate
I had a relationship once goddamn
Somerset why do you always have to make
it about you damn looks like mills and
Somerset are confident which deaths will
take place next the way this list is
numbered to break up the monotony of the
crime scene footage the fellas throw the
top 10 combat handguns up on the wall
welcome to that apartment exactly one
year after you tied to the bed one year
to the date yeah but how remember this
required the lawyers wife to notice a
painting in his office was upside down
which required a good detective to dust
the wall for fingerprints this had been
just Mill's on the case they would have
missed that anniversary he's a nut bag
just because of he's got a library card
doesn't make him Yoda Mills pulls out
the dr.house moment with a random quote
about a fing library card which inspires
Somerset to pay a guy to figure out
who's checking out certain books of the
library yep there was a Brad Pitt eat
something in every movie he's in cliche
even way back in 1995 if you want to
know who's reading purgatory and
paradise lost and helter skelter yeah
yeah ask them to what tell us you mean
they flank purgatory and paradise lost
the fore and Somerset said the stuff
about nuclear weapons and Hitler that
made sense but stuff that a freshman in
high school would check out are you
kidding me library ex machina you mean
to tell me the guy who planned these
murders actually checked out books from
a king library rather than paying cash
to some bookstore for these books the
guy is apparently wealthy so why the
rentals also he was able to use the
alias Jonathan Doe but he couldn't get
away with making up a fake address not
to mention why even used Jonathan Doe
why not darrell bishop or something less
conspicuous bills motley for everyone
involved in this scene John Doe went to
the stormtrooper school of aiming if Doe
is trying to get away then why is he
hanging around waiting to shoot blind
shots up a staircase to try and kill the
ticked up mills Doe somehow managed to
make it out of this window without
disturbing anything on the sink or
knocking over the pill bottles on the
windowsill look I love David Fincher and
he does beautiful movies the fact that I
can't tell who is where and where they
are in relation to each other makes me
think this action scene is no better
than something in Resident Evil
apocalypse rather than just breaking to
avoid hitting the man running in the
middle of the street this cab driver
thinks the better option is to
potentially kill many people on the
sidewalk considering that John Doe
doesn't kill David after this what's the
fucking point it could have hit up here
for hours no one would have known
you might say this is part of his new
plan but Somerset could easily be
seconds away and this whole thing up so
neither of you guys are gonna call back
to the station reporting the assault of
an officer and probably some dead ass
pedestrians goddamnit look I'm sure this
happens and the movies got a long way to
show us how Mills feeds on his emotions
in crap but come on even a guy who's as
pissed as he is would be able to listen
to reason hear and know that breaking
down this door is the end of getting a
conviction then they pay some homeless
person to come up with an eyewitness
account like that's gonna hold up in
court did you know someone actually took
the time to write all this stuff out to
be seen for mere seconds and a movie
that's some detail right there it's
almost like David Fincher knew there
would be some dickhead youtube-channel
trying to point out flaws in this
awesome movie twenty-two years later we
had Mills discovers that the
photographer he told Bob earlier is the
guy they were looking for but how would
they have had him even if you let the
guy take pictures and ask questions and
would they have figured out that he was
the killer Wow
based on this sketch artist the real
surprise ending of this movie is that
John Doe is played by Patrick Stewart on
the subway today a man came up to me to
start a conversation he made small talk
it's lonely man talking about the
weather and other things get the feeling
that John Doe wrote all these volumes of
his journal in the hopes that they would
one day be read and the voice of Morgan
Freeman Somerset turns on his tape
recorder and holds it in a place that in
no way will pick up john doe's voice so
clearly but it does anyway this is where
you realize John Doe doesn't really have
a plan for all seven murders right now
because all the cops can find in his
apartment is the very next victim and
none of the ones after that and yet John
Doe knew he was going to chain the sloth
guy to a bid for a whole year and
intended him to be a third death which
suggests a very particular plan so why
can't they find the others meanwhile
he's taking photos of all his victims
all the way through victim four but not
victim five the pride victim seriously
EBIT if he's planning on becoming NBD
and mills becoming a wrath you should at
least have the pride victim photographed
someone they should be able to find and
prevent the murderer even since she's a
popular model and there's no way John
Doe knew he'd be envied and that the
recently reassigned David would be the
wrath one year in advance
hard to determine if John Doe was
walking with a limp because of the fight
with Mills or because he was still in
character as a verbal Kint considering
the movies came out within a week of
each other yes yes I was married so wait
John knew he could go to this
underground prostitution place to kill
the lust victim but didn't know whom he
was gonna get to do that until that day
also does a prostitute really count as
lust when they're doing it for the money
this guy's been planning his murder
spree for years observing all sorts of
people and writing about it in his
Diaries and he didn't run into a man
cheating on his wife or something to
that effect so much oh yeah remember
Gwyneth Paltrow being in this movie
Looby is overtly reminding you of that
before the final act for no reason at
all before he goes to sleep every night
Morgan Freeman practices his unflappable
stare at the wall which is rightfully
intimidated you metronome I mean come on
this is apparently a well-known model
and he didn't have a picture of her
anywhere in the apartment he didn't plan
this murder yesterday Jesus think about
John Doe Sunday he kills the pride
victim the night before he waits around
for Gabey to go to work then he tries to
play husband with Tracy and it doesn't
work out so he kills Tracy puts her head
in a box finds a guy who can deliver the
box by 7:00 to some remote location
finds a willing taxi driver to drive him
with his bloody clothes to the police
station
no questions asked client also wishes to
inform you that if you do not accept he
will plead insanity across the board
because after all the insanity plea is
used successfully in so many cases not
to mention the fact that you don't just
get to go free when you plead insanity
you have to go to a mental hospital and
live your life as Sarah Connor
if you were to claim insanity this
conversation is admissible two more are
dead the press would have a field day if
they were to find out the police didn't
seem too concerned about finding them
yeah but they're technically already
dead and these are very detective II
detectives so they presumably be able to
track these bodies down over time
basically I'm saying that even though
they don't know in the last two victims
are crazy and John Doe this is a flimsy
reason to go along with this plan
I'm enjoying life right now we caught
the killer and my wife remains
completely on behind such weird thoughts
I have in times like these sure what
this neo-noir gruesome detective movie
needs is yet another police officers
gearing up for battle montage could the
freak be any more vague
I can't wait for you to see I really can
this ends up being an amazing scene but
it's easy to forget that the first
several minutes consist of mills and
douve a Glee trading innocuous insults
and a beast man a disgusting man who
could barely stand up a man who if you
saw him on the street you point him out
to your friends yeah but I'm still
trying to figure out when you actually
saw this guy a shut-in who never
wandered outside in a world this D could
you even try to say these were innocent
people and keep a straight face I mean
you had to know it was coming for
Spacey's performance alone right we see
a deadly sin on every street corner in
every home and we tolerated John Doe
just described what it's like for cinema
sins to see a movie like fate of the
furious become a hit not only in
theaters but on blu-ray in fact one
could say that the whole franchise is
the seven deadly sins of cinema and loi
here's 15 more because we hate got pills
the fact that this man is allowed to get
anywhere near these assholes while
they're supposedly under heavy
surveillance is the least believable
thing in this movie
this guy paid me 500 bucks to bring it
out here man he said he wanted to hear
at exactly 7 o'clock he was covered in
blood but he seemed like a nice guy
I know Somerset knows this killer
wouldn't put a bomb in this box but you
have to be me that he's gonna open it
right here now without truly knowing
what it is and luckily for John Doe he
does because if he follows the normal
procedure Mills never gets a chance to
kill him John Doe has the upper hand
John Doe was certain that Somerset would
be this far away so that he could tell
Mills about killing his wife before he
got back and was able to talk sense into
him I wish I could have lived like man
this reveal is terrific it really is but
the env part of this equation feels
forced as hell doesn't it in the Cardo
was openly contemptuous of Mills but now
as long as he says he admires him this
qualifies as a sim really think that
just chopping off his wife's head was
proven up I says I am via normal life it
seems that Envy is my scene let's talk
about john doe's plant it plans seven
murders to represent the seven deadly
sins
there's no way he knew he would be
envied and that he gets someone to
become wrath once he told him what he
did luckily he ran into hothead David
Mills while he was committing the
murders and decided to change his plan
midstream
also luckily for doe he did not kill an
envy or wrath before this and doe
somehow doesn't see the killing Traci
fucks up the seven deadly sin murders
Traci isn't part of the motif and David
isn't going to die for being wrath
unless it's some sort of symbolic death
I think John knew that finding a
high-profile envy was going to be next
to impossible
so we copped out
decided shrug I guess I'm in V then the
statement is an excellent encapsulation
of the effectiveness of this between
police force Ernest Hemingway once wrote
the world is a fine place and worth
fighting for I agree with the second
part
despite some clear inconsistencies in
this movie the slime the experience of
this movie let's just remove seven cents
you know just because yes this is an
awesome song a fantastic credit sequence
but I still need to take all of the
showers after watching this movie no
time to watch all of it say my name
eizember you're goddamn right you know
what crazy is craziest majority rules
yeah huh take germs for example germs in
eighteenth century no such thing there's
a harsh truth to face no way I'm gonna
make it on the outside I will beat you
like a Cherokee drum but you have to
know not fear know some day you gonna
die the greatest trick the devil ever
pulled was convincing the world he
didn't exist